If I double $50 just 10 times, it's over
$50,000. But if I lose just once, the
challenge is over. But I'm not trading
every day. I'm only trading a clean
reversal setup that fits my strategy.
This isn't some gambling flipping game
where I'm just trying to see how much
money I can make in a crazy amount
exponentially. It's about showing you
what's possible if you follow a
disciplined, consistent strategy. And
above all, have patience. So, let's see
how far I can actually get and put my
money where my mouth is, starting with
just $50. So, day one here, I'm going to
jump in on a trade right here based off
of a 5minute chart. This is in gold.
It's made a clean double bottom. We're
at a good support and it's broken this
downtrend. And so, I'm going to let it
play out based on that. I'm going to put
my stop below this big green
candlestick. The size is a little bit
larger than 50. It's kind of hard when
it's such a small account, but we're
going to see if this can reverse here
and we can get a nice win initially.
And I think it's about to pretty much
close me out here at 1 12x. But you know
what? First trade off $84, 120 up. If it
does close me out right here, it's still
capturing like a 100 bucks. So, I'm
pretty happy with that.
So, I'm in the second trade here, and
it's going pretty well so far. The first
off, the reason why I got in, we're
looking at the NASDAQ. This is on a
larger picture time frame chart,
15-minute chart. Um, we're here right
now, but before we did a big bounce
here, move up, you know, couple, this is
like kind of two days over the weekend,
came back down here, and now it's it's
in a good spot to bounce. And so that's
why then I come into
a smaller time frame chart here. And you
know this is a one minute chart now. You
can see this trend down, pushed up, made
some nice strong move, kind of it
started to find some strength and then
when it broke out, bought in and now I'm
looking for it to pretty much just go
back up to this high right here.
Well, this challenge is going to be
really short. The trade is pretty much
at full loss here, but you know, I guess
that's how it goes sometimes.
[Music]
Oh my god. I kid you not. I literally
thought it was done. Look at this thing.
It reversed like just before my stop
loss here and now we're ripping back up
higher. I'm pretty sure it's just going
to get me out at full win here for a
second as this move is that's a really
nice pullback. Sick trade. I'm glad it
didn't uh wipe me out on these last
seconds. Sometimes it's just so insane
just watching that just almost tick
there and then not like I want to move
my stop loss up right here and then
having it pull back. It's just
psychotic. I think I'm going to move my
stop loss up right here.
So, I'm nervous about this, but again,
the reasons to get in are good. This
could just be like a final push higher
that fails. This candlestick right here
is pretty strong. It's just a an attempt
in a new high and then it's going to
fail. I would like to see how this does
this kind of bottom here and then
continue higher. But, I think if the
NASDAQ gives up, this is going to push
lower. So, I think I'm going to put an
order below this. It's a good setup. New
high, lower high. Big picture is good.
And I'm going to put my stop above the
highs. And I'm going to manage
accordingly. Nice failure there. Again,
like the big thing is this could just
come down and bottom and continue
higher. So, this point just kind of let
it do its thing. See how it plays out
again like this looking even on a fivem
minute. That's a nice fiveminute candle.
Um, but we'll see what it does.
[Music]
One X. That trade is done. Double two.
Now we're on to four.
I'm going to go long here. If it breaks
above this previous candlestick, I think
just to go 1x here, it's a nice signal
to hit just this swing high. We don't
even have to go high that high up. And
that, you know, past that swing. I think
that's totally reasonable of a move.
Just going to see how this plays out.
Okay, we are in. Put my target again.
I'm kind of nervous about this one. It
just doesn't feel great. The setup's
there. Big picture. We're at a nice
level. We've had a massive move down. my
inclination this morning that the market
was going to do a pullback and push
higher. The ES is actually looking
stronger. I would say it's pretty choppy
at this point. I'm taking that trade at
8:30 which is kind of like not a great
hour. But if this candlestick finishes
forming like this on a 5 minute, this
looks clean.
Wait, I'm only in four contracts over
here. No, that's so upsetting. Come on,
just fill that. I need more contracts.
Oh no. Okay, now our risk is better.
Okay, as that is a little funky. Still
legitimately doing this. We're going to
get out when it hits 400 in profit. I
didn't even realize I was in less
contracts. I I was looking at it and I
was like, I'm not up enough money for
where it is based on the chart. So now
it's fine. Now we just need it to go up.
Normally, if I was just going to get out
at basically 1x, I would just get out
right here cuz it's clearly showing some
resistance. And breaking through that
previous swing where that weird news
blip was right here had a random candle
that just shot lower um was just not
worth it essentially. But, you know, I'm
going to let it play out. I mean, it
looks solid. It's going to hit me. So, I
think it's going to be basically at 400,
too. 380, 407,
415. Sick. Done with that. On to risking
800 a trade now, which is pretty close
to my main size.
Okay, so opening up the charts this
morning. The ES futures are look like
they're trying to put in maybe a double
top off of all-time highs. Um, not
really in a spot where I like NASDAQ has
already pushed all-time highs. It's kind
of holding this up trend still. Um, so
kind of mixed signals there. So, not
something super great on that front. Uh,
in terms of gold this morning, big
sell-off into not really a great level.
Um, overall, I think it looks like it's
in more of a downtrend. like it wants
to, you know, continue down and and
somehow find a bounce down here
eventually. Um, with the market looking
bullish, I mean, we could, you know, on
5 minutes, it's a really nice sell-off.
Really overextended. I just I'd be
worried it comes up here off of this
kind of like bottom and just sells off.
Not a ton of opportunities this morning,
but you know, you never know. I I I
never try and just say, "Oh, I know what
the market's going to do," and not watch
it, right? You never know what it's
going to do. It's totally something good
could set up.
I am going to enter in $800 here.
Thinking that we're going to keep this
momentum higher. I just entered in more
contracts than I'd like for some reason.
So, we're slightly larger size than 800.
We are risking more like a,000.
Great. Well, mistakes happen. It's still
a good spot. I want to see us push up
from here. Now granted, I could be a
little early. Like really, I should be
waiting for this 5 minute to close cuz
it could just come up here and and show
a little failure. And you know, maybe I
I then just FOMOed into this. I'm going
to try and close five contracts out
here. See, that's um it's not the right
amount. I shouldn't be in that many. I
would like to be in the correct amount.
Just kind of a an oops, I would say.
Okay, now we just um sit on our hands
and knees and wait for this to hopefully
print money.
Okay, let's see. While I painfully watch
this trade, it's going to bounce, I
swear. Okay, gold all of a sudden is
moving crazily. I don't know what that's
from. That's a really nice sign for this
trade. Maybe it'll just shoot up from
here now. That would be sick. I would
take that. just reverse $800 on me. Five
minute. I mean, five minute looks good.
That's a nice double bottom. 15minute.
Honestly, it looks like it's good
potential to keep going higher. We don't
need it to go that much higher. It
doesn't need to go that high for this.
Oh, if it just rips up and then rips
lower like that, that's going to be an
emotional roller coaster that I would
have preferred to not be a part of.
Come on, baby. Break out. That's all I
need to do. You just break out. If you
break out, I'll give you a cookie. I
have a cookie right here. Look, there's
a cookie. I'll give you a cookie. Come
on, you got it. There you go. There you
go. Yep, that's what we want. Also, if
you're wondering what trading platform
I'm using, it's called Ninja Trader.
I've used it for over 5 years. It's
amazing. I'll leave a link in the
description below this video if you want
to check it out. That candle does not
look good. That is not a good looking
like action. Does not look good. 15
minutes looks about the same. I'm gonna
go walk outside.
Come on. No. It was so close. No, don't
tease me. It's so close. Come on. You
got it. You got it. You got it. I still
have that cookie for you. Come on. 5
minute looks great. Keep it going, my
guy.
Come on. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. There you go. Yes. Oh, it's
closing. Woo. Close. Damn. That was
crazy seeing the contract slowly close
in like real time with that limit order.
On to 1600.
Okay. So, I'm a bit behind this morning,
but looking at let's see, starting with
oil because this looks the best. It's
kind of bouncing. Had a massive sell off
yesterday. Big sell off this morning.
continued kind of at this initial level.
There's a bigger level down here, but
kind of zooming in, it's definitely at a
spot where we could get a bounce. Gold
looks like it could be bouncing here,
too. It just had a spike lower here, and
it's kind of coming into this, you know,
overnight level. And then the market is
big selloff yesterday. So right now both
of these are kind of in the middle of
their range. You know, looking at a one
minute of NASDAQ and ES. They had, you
know, a nice little spike in the open,
but that again, that's not really what
I'm looking for. And maybe see if if the
NASDAQ and the ES make some kind of
drastic move in some direction, like
maybe come down here, set something up
to look like to go long maybe.
I'm going to jump in here. I really hope
I didn't miss it by not having my order
in again. I would probably cry and go
back to bed. Oh my god. Please fill me.
Please pull back just just a smidge and
fill me. Oh, that's brutal. Should I
just chase it there? I'm just trying to
do too many things at once. And now if
it pops up there, I'm like, do I even
want to be in it? Oh, I should I could
have literally just put my order here.
It would have been filled. It literally
one ticked me. What does NASDAQ look
like? I mean, that's a nice signal
overall, you know? I mean, maybe I'm
trying to just like be too too tight
with my entries right now. I don't know.
I'm going to see put in a different
order. See if I can get filled on it. I
really don't want to chase. I think it
looks good, but I don't want to I don't
want to chase up there. Come on, my guy.
Fill me. Even gold looks like it wants
to bottom here. Just be patient. It's
going to come to you. It's really not
that far. It's probably going to come
pull back and pull back a lot. Come on.
Try not to be tortured by this right
now. If this breaks up without me, I'm
definitely calling it a day. Just
looking at these on like a 5minute and
the NASDAQ. They look good. Okay, we're
filled. Okay, now just don't don't just
puke lower on me now. That would just be
rude. Yeah, there you go. Yeah, just get
me. Oh, the torture of trading sometimes
is just a little agonizing. So, I'm
actually in based on the fill, I'm
actually basically in 1,900 over here.
Man, if this just rips up and fills me
for two grand right here, that would be
sick.
No, I don't want to move out to break
even like that yet.
Just going to let it play out.
I don't want to overmanage because I'm
frustrated and all that. Just let it
play out. The stop's in a good spot. Big
picture, it looks great. I think I need
a miracle at this point to save this
trade,
which sucks.
It's happened before. Still in. Wish I
went long gold. That's why we keep it
below the low before it makes an actual
breakout.
I'm kind of surprised cuz this on a 5m
minute looks pretty solid.
And we haven't broken the 5minut signal
yet. Be breaking this low. So that yeah,
that's just kind of surprising.
Feels way more like gambling and intense
with
this challenge of like not wanting to
lose feels way more intense.
And the fact that it's the last trade it
pulled back on me and reversed.
This trade,
I'm not going to say anything. I don't
want to jinx it.
Oh my god. Yes, dude. Oh my god. That
was the most painful thing ever. Oh my
god. I really thought I was screwed on
that one. Oh my god. Woohoo. Oh man,
that was ridiculous. Oh my gosh. That
was intense.
[Music]
So, I've actually decided to stop this
challenge right here. That last trade
was pretty emotional. You saw how up and
down it was. The whole idea with trading
is to make money. Eventually, I'd lose
if I'm betting my account every time.
Just to show you my results here, this
took me pretty much 20 days, but I'm up
a total of over $3,000.
It's really important to know when to
actually stop and reset because
otherwise you're going to go on a
massive win streak and blow it. And so,
I hope this has been really helpful. If
you want to get my free guide that goes
through all the candlestick patterns
that I use, you can get that in the link
in the description. And you can check
out this video right here to learn even
more about this strategy to actually go
into what I look for every trade versus
this kind of style of video that is
really just showcasing how it works.